what are your key takeaways from
everything that's going on and what
should the average american or the
average person worldwide really
uh be on the lookout for and pay
attention to
look if this is going to be a complete
left field the type of feedback i'll
give to you guys so i'm watching a guy
who's doing an interview from ukraine
and he says we were not expecting this
there was a longest line today in gas
station where people are leaving they
didn't have weapons they didn't have
this they didn't have that to the
average person i would say proper
preparation prevents poor performance
look
when i got when i got married
my wife i got a range rover and i parked
it outside
one day we come i go to sleep i wake up
in the morning the entire window was
shattered
stereo system was stolen everything the
next day i bought a shotgun and i bought
a gun okay
i bought a shotgun and a gun because i
had a kid chico was born and i said it's
my job to and by the way i'm living in
california doing that and i'm a military
background so i kind of know how to use
this stuff because i used it for the
years that i was in the military
so
if you have a wife and a kid and a
husband and family and people to protect
it's kind of your duty to protect them
what do you do with that proper
preparation prevents poor performance
you got to secure your family right
number two
these guys didn't go to the gas station
if you're kind of seeing crisis has
taken place you got to look at yourself
what is crisis today i've been saying
for the longest time
cash is king for the individual not for
the billionaire not for the millionaire
not for all those other guys
but cash is king where you got to have
an emergency fund ready in case
something does take place okay now on
top of that if you go and look at
buffett you remember how everybody was
talking about why does buffett have 200
billion dollars in cash what does he
know that we don't know what does he
know that we don't know
maybe he was expecting something like
this to happen maybe he was expecting a
correction or a world or something to
happen where the economy may take a hit
but the economy hasn't taken a hit yet
but the biggest thing for the average
person is stay alert stay alive educate
yourself listen to commentary on both
sides
try not to listen to the commentary of
just one side because then you're going
to be fooled first thing i did when i'm
watching everything i'm reading articles
from people who hate trump i'm reading
articles from people who hate biden if
you only read articles from people that
hate biden you're gonna have a blind
spot and if you only read articles from
people that hate trump you're also gonna
have a blind spot do not be naive today
okay do not mean these guys that don't
wake up this morning wanted to put food
on your table they woke up this morning
wanted to make sure they look good in
front of camera and the legacy shows
good about them being a president you
and i have to go do that we have to go
take care of our families and look again
another reminder proper preparation
prevents poor performance and stay alert
stay alive educate yourself
um but having said that my computer here
is about to die i really enjoyed uh uh
jumping on and having this dialogue with
you guys for the people in ukraine man
our our prayers are with you uh i i i
know war it sucks i remember that as a
kid till today it's got an effect on me
i watch certain movies and i immediately
go back to iran some of these effects
are gonna have effects on these kids
that's gonna last decades
but uh you know god willing there's
going to be some kind of a decision
being made here quickly
for this to end because war never
benefits the world politically sometimes
it does it benefits some companies but
it doesn't benefit the people and that's
what my biggest concern is today a lot
of regular people that are innocent they
haven't done anything wrong they're
being affected by this
hopefully this sense very quickly
[Music]